supporters of jailed russian opposition
politician alexei navalny are set to go
on trial today in moscow
they're being accused of extremism the
court case is the toughest attempt yet
to dismantle navalny's nationwide
network of support
prosecutors accuse his anti-corruption
foundation of trying to destabilize
russia
if found guilty members could face
prison sentences
and be prevented from running in
september's parliamentary elections
let's get more on this story with our
moscow correspondent emily sherwin
hi emily what is at stake here for alexi
navalny supporters and for his
organization
well if these three organizations
are labeled extremist that essentially
means that their work is completely
impossible in russia going forward
in fact navain's
network of offices across the country 37
of them
have already had to close down they've
stopped their work in anticipation
of the verdict in this trial and people
involved with the three organizations
being tried today even in the past could
face
faith jail time and the thing that i
think is dangerous about this
label also is that we don't really know
how it will be
used in the case of alexei navalny's
organizations it could even mean that
people
who posted about say an anti-corruption
investigation that navalny did in the
past
on their facebook page could face fines
or even up to 15 days
in jail and essentially that means that
all of navalny's supporters could
um face having kind of a black mark um
on their record
and and also uh alexey navalny's allies
have said that it essentially is
the final attempt to dismantle their
structures across the country
and emily this really is being seen as
part of this expanding crackdown on
russian opposition
i want to ask you about that in a moment
but first let's take a look at
how alexia navalny and his organization
have inspired a new wave of activists
february in moscow we're filming at the
memorial to the murdered opposition
leader boris nemtsov
just before the sixth anniversary of his
death a young man who looks like a
tourist
tells us he's just turned his own life
upside down
yeah i was in the police i resigned when
alexi navalny was sentenced to prison
it takes courage to resign for political
reasons and especially to speak out in
public
but sergey is determined
you can't be scared the whole time boris
nemtsov was not afraid and
neither is alexi navalny it depends on
all of us
every one of us has a stake in the
future of our country
28 old sergey was a police officer for
five years
now he lives on his savings blogging on
youtube and
instagram he posted his resignation
online on the day navalny was convicted
sergey was still wearing the police
uniform
the verdict against navalny was the last
straw
he was also dismayed by the brutal
police crackdown on demonstrations
a police officer kicked a woman to the
ground there were no charges against him
and he wasn't even fired
i don't want to be part of this system
anymore i'm ashamed of the violence even
though i wasn't there
in march sergey traveled to moscow
attending a seminar for local
politicians
organized by civil rights activists
among the speakers prominent opposition
figures
within minutes police stormed the room
they arrest
everyone present including one speaker
we were in the middle of interviewing
of course it's dangerous opposing the
government but this is about russia's
future
sergey himself was arrested for the
first time in his life
he was released and later fined his
former colleagues he says would not
understand his actions
like most in russia they are not
interested in politics just
three cases have been reported of police
officers resigning over the latest
violent unrest
emily you know we saw it there the
kremlin appears to be steadily cracking
down
on the russian opposition is this all
about elections that are taking place in
september
absolutely um i think it seems pretty
clear now that
the kremlin doesn't want any opposition
candidates to even be
allowed to register at least that seems
to be the signal
that we've been getting in the past few
weeks for example there's this
new law which means that anyone uh
deemed to be
extremist or connected with an extremist
organization will be barred from running
in the upcoming elections
that law according to experts seems to
be
squarely aimed at navigating
organizations navain's allies even in
anticipation
of that court verdict that we were
talking about earlier and it's not just
people associated with navalny
for example in the past a few days and
weeks
two prominent opposition figures were
arrested
here in russia andrey pivawarov who was
the coordinator of
open russia a civil society organization
was actually taken out of a plane as he
was trying to fly to warsaw he was
arrested and dmitry gudkov of well-known
opposition politician was also
detained um then released and he has now
left the country he's gone
to ukraine and and we've also been
seeing a crackdown
in other areas not just on politicians
but also on
uh critical media outlets um ngos and
even on
people who took part in protests back in
the winter
and emily what about alexia navalny
himself can you bring us up to date on
his situation
well we know that this week he was
transferred from
a hospital within a prison back to just
a normal
prison he was in hospital because he had
been on hunger strike
doctors called on him to stop his hunger
strike because they said he was close to
dying
he was actually uh protesting the fact
that um
he was not allowed to see independent
doctors even though he was suffering
from symptoms
he said that we're connected with the
fact that he was poisoned
with using a military nerve agent last
year
now it seems that his uh health
condition is stable
and his spirits are up he's been joking
um in letters to his lawyers and uh to
his wife that
um are then posted on instagram uh but
he's still in prison and
seems to it seems that he'll be there
for the upcoming future
emily sherman they're reporting from
moscow thank you
you